cringe report today we're gonna be
cringing to something else as you guys
watch this video we want you to tell us
at which point did Aaron make you want
to check out if you don't know who Aaron
is you're about to discover you're gonna
know where it is
oh you won't you all learn today we
brought together seven vegans one is a
liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize what's your
favorite I'm gonna talk about all the
time what are you gonna talk about I get
a contract but swap out the beef and get
some beans in there also swap out the
sour cream and the cheese yeah something
use eggs in there like in their raps I
hope they don't yeah I hope they don't
either because then that wouldn't be
vegan
[Music]
[Laughter]
I hope not cook are not vegan thank you
you are detestable who are you and
considering the vegan stereotypes this
is a good strategy to stay in the game
yeah cuz there's zero doubt in my mind
that this short hair green dressing
obnoxious is his veto grace s0 no oh the
way she's going at this guy are you sure
that you're I don't know why she was
coming at me I don't know if it's like
the way I look I don't look like a vegan
um I'll be honest I everything on bread
I have to because like I just I'm a
recent vegan I've been vegan for like
five months it's a challenge I did for
myself
remember who came in the name for my
game I am I think you need to hear the
Freestyle you know I'm good I believe
you I believe you know hey game the game
for the
everybody just on my name steady hands
always no track never going back always
been next you know got the man I have a
question what are y'all favorite
restaurants you guys check out in North
Hollywood is this like awesome it's
really it's Asian vegan yes yeah you
know you I really been taking I talked I
took my friend Hannah she's actually a
big youtuber as well everything that
came out of his mouth was super random
Brandon what do you eat for breakfast
this morning I had buckwheat buckwheat
hot cereal add almond milk and some
water okay
who eats buckwheat in the morning like I
know people do but I'm looking at him
and his body language and how he's
telling me and I'm going you just had
buckwheat
why is everyone here at vegan I'm vegan
because I actually moved out here I felt
like I was like all right if I mess up I
can keep on doing it so I challenged
myself on five months in and I was like
all right I'm gonna continue doing it
because you got to be you talk like
every spit that comes out of your mouth
is the throne of virus remedy that's how
entitled you are this girl speaks with
the energy of the Karen saying can I
talk to your manager social justice
warriors everything about you is just
like I'm about to step with authority
but you know what listen that dude won't
shut the so I get you're right now that
she's right because she's detestable yes
it's all about the delivery if you
deliver a pizza upside down
fill it pizza but the deliveries I've
been vegan for almost ten years combined
started off when I was 21 years old I
was drinking heavily and I just wanted
to be feeling like better in my body so
you were the person before division and
you silly person now I went vegan kinda
has like a transition I was pescetarian
for ten years
and we have two minutes okay I'm not
crazy I want to fight now
oh what a fight now hey might wanna ask
questions huh who paid you to buy hmm
when where who saw moosa' I'm not crazy
yes you know how men die sooner than
women yeah I get it
that's like when men are married to
women who scream like her they just want
to die sooner absolutely I get it
why is your favorite documentary oh I
helped you though with that
Oh help me go vegan I kind of watch like
those YouTube one which ones like what
what name one I don't remember the names
I like saw them in the blogs that I was
talking about and like which blog um it
was called it was like this girl her
name is Emma I gave her the sign I liked
mm-hmm you don't know what blog you
don't know what post you don't know this
you don't know you don't know anything
what is your favorite soap that you use
oh my gosh I'm more vegan for like food
related reasons right but typically like
if you're vegan you use all your power
I identify as vegan but I do it more so
for food-related reasons I identify as
vegan I self identify as vegan if this
for me that I am I just identify ass
okay that is my journey into my veganism
it's me I wouldn't agree with that I
don't care I'm not I don't care but so
if you eat one meat patty one time
you're no longer vegan no longer I don't
think it's that black no it is a scary
you could always find an industry that
you contribute to you that
you know I mean yeah I know but
according to Aaron it's not I'm just I'm
being Aaron right now so you stopped
eating but you then use the soap that
uses animal products nope I don't think
is the worst thing not a nine United
more you're not yeah technically you
shouldn't you should have watched for it
you have a responsibility and you're not
doing the most right now you wear a
leather I don't know whether it's
interesting I own leather but I don't
buy leather is leather that has been
bought years ago that I still have that
I feel this kind of like wasteful I like
throwaway important things you don't buy
yeah because we vote with our dollars
exactly I think like in this circle like
there would still be people who like
identify themselves as vegan even if
it's like food-related or like something
else but I think like the odd man how
would it be someone who like yeah is
like me like just doing it for free yes
yeah ask me questions too I like
questions I don't know if this guy's
really just doubly smart and he's the
mole
he thinks so he's pretending to be this
annoying but I remember having an
earlier video
he was pretty obnoxious but he seemed a
little bit smarter than this this seems
really awkward to one yeah cuz when he
was in the other video he wasn't this
awkward he's being them even more
actually don't you I don't Yanni yes I I
don't I just don't at all I
honey honey isn't vegan I think they
made me feel like my reason for being a
vegan wasn't good enough because it
wasn't coming from the same place that
they were I have a question yeah so okay
everyone think about the immediate
circle how many folks in your circle are
vegan I'm supported by my circle yeah
like they thought I was unhealthy at
first because I wasn't getting enough to
eat
mm-hm and I don't hold what guess is you
so far you've said that you don't really
consider yourself vegan I think she
doesn't like Asians I'm not like you
because the way she's gunning for my man
is pretty intense no why why feed dogs
I don't know what it is I don't know I
don't know what it is this is intense
I wouldn't drill him out because he
thinks he's in we're talking we're
looking for a mold yeah
not someone that is not well-informed
right try my best
oh no it's been like less than year like
eight months actually they're the fresco
style at Taco Bell is supposed to be
vegan Ida he didn't mention that he said
that he got the taco and then he removed
everything and then he mentioned that
later on I have seen vegan youtubers who
like go to talkin like you can make it
vegan just to show people that like it
can be like convenience I don't know why
you guys you did not just pull the
weight I'm the victim here
you've been persecuted mom Han for like
ten minutes about this Taco Bell
then the others are like no this is real
so aren't vegans who go there yeah I
don't know why you guys are getting so
do the problem you're the one I hate
when people are obnoxious and rude and
then act like they're the victim
afterwards let me push your button and
then after that the question we react to
this and then you're like oh you
triggered me this is a type of girl to
pull the trigger be like why the bullet
come out what's your favorite candy
favorite candy most candies without
gelatin in it nerdy one name one nerd
sorry kids
okay those aren't vegan I thought they
were okay maybe I'm not a vegan he's
definitely not the mole but he's
definitely having an existential crisis
like cave on this she'll be like I'm
gonna connect with other vegans until I
get out to try god bless you bro
Jubilee pays for your therapist a
shoulder deep you see this is a hope
this is people that are that that that
have the same way of thinking right but
it just showcases sometimes how within
the same room some people are gonna
murder
each other because while you're not
vegan you're not knowing you think you
are but you when that person is doing
better than anybody other that's not
from your group but you're ready they're
just like yeah no you're not you're not
you're not you're not it just shows you
how some people would be some of these
groups sometimes some extremists are
very cannibalistic seem like they're
gonna be able to delete their people
even if they're doing better than other
people what's your favorite game it
didn't seem that his ethics and his
values were in alignment with the diet
because typically when you are vegan
everything surrounding you matches that
[Music]
that's you're delusional do you think
vegans or some kind of special breed
that they are all like 100% vegan you
know there's people who follow vegan
diet
who don't you who wear leather there's
people who extremists there's people who
bodybuild who don't use protein shakes
don't do everything bodybuilder type
related there's people who do UFC
training and don't do all the different
forms of mixed martial arts it's not
because you're engaged in something
necessarily gonna do it to the hundred
percent like everyone else that was then
you're not really you know I could
probably look at something that you're
doing and it relates to some form animal
cruelty guaranteed it's impossible to
eliminate everything and so if you're
using a tear system you have to use a
tier system because at some point
there's always some form of animal
cruelty involved in something that
you're doing there is there's no way to
100% live off the grid you pay taxes it
goes to agricultural centers it goes to
farmers you are subsidizing what are you
gonna live away from every country no
there are tears to this stuff you try to
take what actions that you can take not
everyone's gonna be at the same left
she's the best
it's cringy bro it's like what you said
earlier about cannibalism you're right
she's the best and if you don't abide by
our rules and our how she does it the
best yeah then you're not yeah
be considered I'm not like really a part
of the vegan community I feel like I
have one vegan friend I could have had
five vegan friends but they voted me out
so so we raise our hand if we think he's
still in here
he basically snitched on himself yeah he
said do we raise their hand if we think
that he's still in here he oh that he's
been eliminated hmm just gendering it is
interesting and yeah I feel a little bit
more secure in this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I know with him fortunately Aaron gives
a bad name to vegan yeah super obnoxious
all of them were pretty cool her bad I
didn't lose a moral high-ground that
vegans a lot of them seem to think that
they live on and then they speak down to
others from and it was weird watching
her do that to somebody else who was
really trying you know like I already
see vegans do that to people who eat
meat I see them do it I like restaurants
and stuff like that okay kind of but
just seeing her do it to somebody who's
really trying and making an effort was
really hard to watch well I think that
was the point of the video I don't think
I cringe so much I was just like that's
not greatest you'd rinsed but the
problem is the most extreme is the most
obnoxious ones are the loudest and
that's what we're gonna remember hmm so
as you guys watch this video we want you
to tell us
at which point did Aaron make you want
to check out are you ever thought about
going vegan yeah of course I have I have
hmm and steaks happen well done no no
medium rare medium rare at best I'm mad
at you I don't like my my meat ruined
mmm I think I'm gonna probably turn
vegetarian it's possible
I mean pescetarian a bit of fish well
that's it for today's you go tell us
what you guys think you want to hear
your comments below
[Music]